une star du baseball américain au
service de la france l'entraîneur bruce
bochy étaient présents au stade jean
marc et celle de montigny le bretonneux
à l'origine de nombreuses victoires avec
les giants de san francisco
cette pointure du baseball animer une
master class auprès de 120 enfants
passionnés au programme technique de
frappe de lancer ou encore de rattrapage
de balle
globe je fais quelque chose que j'aime
entraîner au baseball donner des
conseils place à aucune attaque en tout
cas si je peux aider les jeunes enfants
en france et au développement du
baseball dans le pays j'ai le sentiment
de faire mon travail et alors diab un
retour à ses racines pour cet américain
né en charente maritime il a rejoint
l'équipe de france de baseball en tant
qu'entraîneur pour les qualifications à
la world baseball classic 2023 une
compétition internationale le fait
d'avoir bruce à la tête de cette équipe
de france a permis peut-être à des des
joueurs de se dire ben j'aimerais bien
participer à cette compétition avec
l'équipe nationale française et donc ça
a permis d'attirer des joueurs qu'on
n'aurait pas forcément pu rencontrer
cette pointure du baseball une aubaine
pour ces jeunes bien que la star
américaine ne soit pas toujours très
connu en france est ce que tu connais
c'est bruce
aujourd'hui
quand on dit que ce choix aura joué dans
des gros clubs aux états unis on se dit
on à une star en face de nous et c c'est
impressionnant l'occasion d'améliorer sa
technique grâce à de précieux conseils
j'ai amélioré ma technique de bol
antérieur et de vrac extérieurs ont
changé la position de la baule
je ne vais pas leur apprendre quelque
chose de spécifique je veux juste qu'ils
prennent du plaisir et s'amuser si tu
prends du plaisir tu peux faire de
bonnes choses si nous pouvons les
inspirer alors on a fait notre boulot
ces jeunes joueurs auront bientôt
l'occasion d'admirer les performances de
l'équipe de france de baseball elle
disputera les qualifications à
ratisbonne en allemagne du 16 au 21
septembre pour le tournoi international